where's the video of that try my product
so what do you got to lose try my
product dude there's this infomercial
how about when you realize you remember
an infomercial when you were young and
you
go oh [__] today's gonna be a day you go
oh
[__] today's gonna be Nostalgia
City might as well [__] start getting
some might as well get Rainbow Bright
and some Dipping
Dots and a Razor
scooter I I remembered this the other
day
dude the end of this the last second of
this is so ill dude but this guy is do
you need to know how to operate a
computer hi I'm John Sher CEO and
founder of video Professor dude video
Professor like it's a [__] someone in
Arkham Asylum hello I'm the video
Professor I will show you how you're
going to die in a video HS and then do
that it seems like everywhere I go these
days somebody is recognizing me as the
video Professor ah where's recognizing
dude hey are you are you the video
Professor imagine getting mistaken for
the video Professor are you the video
Professor oh are you [__] no that's
because we've been teaching people how
to operate computers for over 14 years
now bro when did this come out over 14
years
no no no that was yeah way longer you
just pay a small shipping in hand I'm
going to end the reason I'm going to do
this is because I know that once you try
my product you'll come back to us for
all your computer learning needs and if
this doesn't teach you how to run a
computer I'll even refund your shipping
and handling dude the end of this here
we go we're going to the end this is so
gangster the end of
this so what have you got to lose try my
product
dude try my product dude we would say
that all the time refund your shipping
and handling so what have you got to
lose try my product call video Professor
now for your free lesson from Windows
word quick and many more call in the
next 10 minutes and this free gift will
be yours the anytime organizer is the
calendar diary dress book and journal on
your PC so you'll never miss an
appointment again remember you must call
now to get your free CD and extra free
gift so don't delay call Now call 1 800
49265 how many different people tell
need to say call now there were three
people so what do you got to lose try my
product why does he say it like that so
what do you need to lose traa product
dude
wow John sheerer dude [__] absolutely
hung himself you know what I mean for
sure hung himself 12 years
ago please try my
product the video Professor such a
mouthful
call it something cool you know